you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hello welcome back to gay
sports continuing coverage of the
electronic triple 2016 I'm your host
Daniel Dwyer delighted to be back on the
coop stage brought to you by lego star
wars the force awakens Utley
contractually obliged despite that we're
going right delighted to be joined by
Liam O'Brien re ashley johnson and laura
bailey oh hi of critical role we're
we're here to chatting to you and the
other 40 people in your yes i'll be
joining through a whole gaggle there to
talk about III talking bad video games
to talk about voice acting and a lot
more as well here we go the first things
first have you guys seen any of III yet
yes a little bit you were here all day
yesterday I was here while I was here
Jim well I don't even know what Dana's I
was here Tuesday okay here all day
Tuesday day 15 of e3 you're on day 25 um
and then yes and now today I'm tired
alright but it's great I mean I haven't
really seen that much stuff for how long
if that I've been sitting here I'd like
this little lines see you guys at
records like it's locally right you're
all like la natives ish yeah yeah but
sometimes we go other places to record
as well like if they need crunch
recording or something we may fly to
Boston or Seattle or Vancouver or
something like that la is definitely the
mothership but they sort of spit us out
in pods the other yeah yeah I mean it's
them it's a sort of mothership of you
know nor Reggie I don't know why you
call acting in relation to your voice
acting acting miss actor yeah kareena
idea screen acting yeah although most so
much of what we do now is performance
capture as well yeah like yelling Laura
first of all before we get into the
topic we have at hand it was it like
getting up on the stage it was so
nerve-racking I was so excited when they
asked me to do it and then the minute I
realized what I would be doing I like I
almost throw up on the spot so you're
actually playing live yeah
it was it was crazy we practiced like
insane amounts and um yeah it was great
hey sweaty hands sweaty hands shaking
hands I need the whole file and I had to
talk i was mad she's got the talking to
come on talk and then play a game yeah i
was watching and i was like haha just so
nervous oh well the topic of the hour is
perfect you guys are here because we're
talking about a female protagonist video
game has changed over the course of over
the past 10 20 years and all that work
that is still to be done in relation to
this ram earlier i was yesterday i was
we had at one of the community managers
for Tomb Raider on talking about the
20th anniversary of Lara Croft yes like
for a lot of people especially like some
of our generation that was like the sort
of the the I mean the first sort of main
female protagonist the first iron man
yes like for you guys who who was the
first was a cross yeah yeah same I mean
I'll video thing in high dive off of
cliffs yes you know as a sort of I have
no shortage of people to play to project
myself into as a white male but what was
it like for you guys I sort of like
young women experiencing tomater because
it's something that like obviously it's
completely different to what you know
myself Ali and particularly would have
experienced I feel like I mean it was I
i do remember making a note of that when
that came out I was like oh wow it's
it's a female character and it it did
seem out of the norm a chain capable and
Athleta yeah right huge um better yeah
and wealthy I really have I think I
remember thinking how cool it her braids
looked alright yeah we're all going Oh
neat yes
I remember but even back then there was
this sort of there was an air of like
sexualization happening there as well
we're like that character as well you
know especially no way was marketed
perhaps maybe outside of the games there
was this sort of edge to it I remember
you know seeing lara croft on the cover
of like various like fashion magazines
and stuff but then that was one thing
but then it also unlike what we've
called lads mags back in Britain which
were like you know you're FHM's and your
Maxim sins oh yeah let me my first the
first choice I ever did for video games
was blood rain right in the blood
against Anna she was in Playboy right
you know I mean and I uh I didn't know
any difference when I was doing the
voice for it but let's just have a good
it's it's come to where it is now is so
awesome so for the people who don't know
who are some of the like [ __ ] to see you
guys have portrayed in video games Liam
which ladies which ladies I've ever day
late anyway uh I've golem in shadow of
mordor I'm in Bar Harbor that just came
out I'm Illidan Stormrage in the world
of warcraft i also directed the video on
lego star wars for really yeah wonderful
suck yeah excellent hi mr. Hobson a
pretty good director you did that you
did the sabersense yeah I supplied all
the saber sounds for the game result
yeah um okay so i worked with laura on a
couple of things I played gorgeous the
little robot and tales from the
borderlands so freaking adorable and I
was Ellie in the last of us um and yeah
the other ones that I'm blaming up for
total I'm in Minecraft hotels minecraft
mostly Petra um thanks Laura yeah I
always like go blank when people ask
like I don't know I've never got a 50
page just like dude
I'd wanna pay your cell phone ah
bloodrayne Jaina Proudmoore and world of
warcraft oh my god i blanked too and I
know it's her oh no Fiona and tell us
where the borderlands and I've lost it
Elena and resident evil late and Reza
dville sick right and a lot of life
lunch re eat in Gears of War floor
they're coming out hey there's that Oh
first Larten veil and halo 5 yeah so
there's this list I'm pursuing first
light [ __ ] and if in a second son in
first yes yes a all of them just say all
of that I don't know why I covered my
mic like I was gonna whisper is this way
so how long have you been working then
in this line of work has it been like
five six seven eight years you've been
in there a while you've been an answer I
think first I think for in terms of
video I think I've been been doing it
since I was about 13 right wow yeah I've
been doing it since I was 18 right now
normal was it the same for you lee like
22 or 23 right yeah yeah well Laura and
I kind of came in through the like anime
dubbing doggy yea orsa i started in
Dragon Ball Z yeah so I guess within
that time have you seen much of a shift
in terms of I guess like how developers
have been tackling female protagonist in
these video games yes even in the last
three years I've seen a growth in how in
the character size that come down even
when we're just auditioning for things
the way things are outlined it's it's
changed so much because piano presumably
lots of video games have women in them
there've always been you know and then
as sort of caste get more and more
voiced I imagine years back it was you
I'd like your protagonist and then some
sort of side characters but then we're
now in a situation where everyone's
getting voices but are you seeing the
shift where it's more and more sort of
main characters are like the focus of it
and like instead of just telling male
stories with female sort of side
characters hey there's our sporting yeah
there's like stories like being told
from a female perspective I feel like
just seeing
the demos that have been presented at e3
in 11 years yeah there's been a huge
increase it's definitely gonna grow in I
mean just talking about where it started
where you know now you just have like a
normal female in a game yeah you know
that's not over sexualized or she's just
just a just a just little plain old lady
know what and I think it's great because
it's like we have that for guys and I
know this is like such a hot topic still
yeah and I think as long as it's still
talked about then it's probably still
something that needs to be dealt with
you know I think as long as once we stop
talking about it and it becomes sort of
a norm normal thing for just to have
normal female characters and for men to
you know it's it's we're seeing a little
bit more of that in games I feel like
across the board yeah I mean it shows
like an overall maturity of the industry
and end of the audience and then also i
feel like the industry is realizing or
acknowledging in the last two or three
years who the audience is yeah the
audience has changed so it's it's us all
getting sort of smarter and savier and
wanting to have something for everybody
and the good news is like this year
officially there are too many games
right yeah well you want to do all the
guy dude bro games there there there
it's nothing's being replaced it's just
you know it's adding 2 pi yeah yeah and
I feel like it's cool that you're seeing
just regular people in games in general
yeah like in uncharted for not giving
any spoilers away but like Troy Baker's
character Sam like he's great like he
has like a little bit of like a receding
hairline are like you know the don't get
off Sam here and like you know the guy
who's you know it the the main guy it's
a jail I feel like I'm gave me spoilers
away I'm so sorry but I'm not but he's
just such a normal dude yeah might as
well they're just like I love seeing
that in games I mean obviously range is
another example real and we don't want
to get rid of the commandos and though
obviously
the game yeah like I'm presumably as
well you know writing in video games has
you know matura talaash writers have
gotten better writers are coming from
other industries so for years and years
we were just basically looking at
stereotypes of all descriptions right
and even the stories themselves we're
quite like Roche like we sort of knew
what was going on so you you guys work
with writers a loss yes it's do you
think just the core writing in video
games is getting better in above itself
yes it's a more and more cinematic and
more powerful and scripts one of the
games I just worked on well I was I was
crying just reading the script through
it was it was so awesome I was like I
need to work on this project it's
amazing yeah I mean even like I feel
like tales from the borderlands was so
well written and it's I mean a nut of
course I'm not saying like oh all games
need to have normal people in them you
know it obviously depends on the game
and that was fantasy and their robots
but it was just so well written yeah
like I I've definitely across the board
I feel like a lot of writers from either
TV or film it's I feel like some writing
and video games sometimes better right
then film or TV it's like the watermarks
rising over yeah it's the same for
acting and writing and directing an
industry all that you know 30 years ago
all the actors writers and directors
were thinking what is this stuff no
thank you yeah then we all grew up right
or judge who idolized this stuff and
love to have grown up and become
professionals and we don't we're not
leaving so we're just bringing our
growed up yeah / teeth yeah and that
presumably makes your job a lot more
interesting than as well because yes
probably sick of doing the same
characters every yeah a couple of years
wait I love it don't get me wrong I will
gladly play that can carry over and over
again about it thank you got work yeah
yeah that's good stuff and so I guess
let's talk about some of the games that
are at this year with strong female
photographers already said we've seen it
at e3 any of them jumping out to you
we've like horizon zero dawn Oh as hell
I mean horizon
yeah it looks great and then record
looks so fun to write I mean I know yeah
I can't wait for that have you guys
gotten hands-on with any of those
neither of those we even got hands all
day like that doughnut oh yeah it's
terrible name is me this is what III is
about it's for people who haven't played
that [ __ ] oh please little bit so sad
so what about stuff that's come out in
recent years I guess then have you guys
played the latest tomb raider sagan so
ladies tomb raider oh I have not I'm
behind on Tomb Raider i'm behind on so
many game I spent all my time playing
fallout 4 price yeah and uncharted 4
that's right of course great yeah
although you knew what was gonna happen
problem no well you know I mean I mean I
went in and filmed but I film you know
specific little scenes yeah most of the
in-game dialogue that I did was for
multiplayer hmm so I didn't know all the
other ins and outs of the storyline room
is really great to get to play through
young busting stuff what about yourself
would fall outs I mean fallout is what
I've been playing in my small amount of
time I mean we work we work so often I
got kids yeah and we kind of play D&D a
fair amount right yeah sorta cemented in
what little free time I had what I mean
I do I play fallout like two hours or a
week maybe which is not enough not
satisfying but that's a great value
proposition though yeah that's like 60
votes Oh like you're done for you i buy
games i buy all yeah I we have a mom
Michelle I'm going over watch which is
super fun wise yeah yet yes full minute
all right I know we need to get on it
get all right all right a lot more snack
and I'm catching up on Witcher 3 cuz I'm
i'm so behind in games we're just yo
just it's so hard to find the time
totally I mean on every game seems to be
turning into an epic I mean every year
it's amazing and you want to try not
everything yeah even like I'm charred
there was another one where it was like
this game is like 20 hours lives I did
not expect it to be that long I kept
going I know I kept I was at the end of
the nose there was another chapter and
is like oh yeah we-we've out reach the
point in the industry where even the
game journalists who review games are
saying I just don't have I couldn't play
that one
time there's so much content ya know
that's like I so I'm why would you come
to us who we play everything would you
have liked from youtuber who like only
plays naughty dog games I'm not sure if
that exists maybe miss erotic tales like
overwatch is a good example of that you
know which characters you like an
overwatch um I like Hans oh um I've been
playing his mercy a lot I think also
because because we do play D&D and I do
play as a cleric and our DNA and you've
got a hand well yeah and so mercy I
think it's kind of fun playing as that
character cuz you're kind of just like
I'll go through and I'll heal um I feel
like we're gonna actually obligated to
say McCree right he's right over there
you're a nerd I know does he do that
when he's playing all the time he
doesn't shooters in light as you draw
people were they up just over the voice
I honest wonderful but a stupid play
yeah I feel like our voices when we play
online don't actually transfer bright
played online and everybody just thinks
I'm a little boy Stannis yeah yeah no I
swear I'm a girl is that beneficial
though like have you seen a difference
in playing online as a woman like is it
cuz I've not gotten easier because I
remember friends in college who would
want to play like gears of war with us
and then turn off for Mike as it was
like you don't want to hear it but might
marry a kiss a minute anyone heard it
was like I generally turn I mute
everybody just because if I'm if I'm
playing something aggressive right just
because i am not as good as everybody
else and i know they're gonna talk yeah
to me but um but outside of that i never
experienced any kind of hmm meanness to
me like when I was playing all my MMOs
and stuff yeah everybody that's a nice
crowd is really nice MMO crowd are
pretty different yo get like great name
yeah
screw and then when we play call of duty
we're all just kind of playing with each
other so yeah I mean I yell at Ashley
non-stop non-stop we'll just do private
private games call of duty Troy and
Travis and yeah yeah good stuff those
games are confusing though because all
of us have done so much battle chatter
in there that you're not sure if you're
hearing I that happens a lot alike yeah
what why are you Aaliyah me Travis son
he's like oh no you're not i understand
as the soldier in the game I huh did you
do before you to reboot there was a year
where I was one of the main factions in
one of the modern warfare and I ok
played in a group and people and know
any of the main factions yeah we was it
tight I it was a military game ok and I
was the one saying get to the hardpoint
gets point a are taking our base and
nobody knew what the what the heck was
going on yeah you can say can I what you
want yeah especially you guys with your
fantastic voices yeah does that happen
where you don't realize one of you was
in a game and then you're like here's
something and it's like yeah I feel like
isn'ta last two games it's it's Skyrim
and fall out that it's nonstop walk you
and you're doing yeah your friends well
right over and over again targets
presumably that's one game where they
had to employ quite a lot of you yeah
endless amounts of actors on her and
everybody's doing like four different
characters just because there's so many
if you're lucky in Fallout New Vegas I'm
every other NCI populated the desert in
all of humanity my children are
everywhere else in uri yeah yeah you're
is the the other side on NCR but who did
you play in in far harbor than they owe
a robot that I don't want to spoil right
an innate and a guy with a chip on his
shoulder that they didn't tell me his
name so okay I know it and so do you do
you know a lot about the context okay
because you're talking about it earlier
about have sometimes you don't see the
big pic yeah now you gotta have a good
voice director who's got it all in their
brain otherwise here yeah he actually
did some
voice directing on Last of Us oh really
and I learned so much from the sessions
that I had with him because working as
an actor and then also directing he can
kind of know how to get an actor to
where they need to be yeah it was
massively over every actor takes
different cues so you have to find that
bigger words for everybody to like help
them yeah get to where they need to come
times your you're saying one thing to
elicit a response they don't even know
you're you're digging for the good but
the easiest thing is hiring the right
people then you take a nap under the
desk because right yeah I'm presumably
that's also gotten a lot better like
this must have been way more difficult
in like the Wild West years you know ten
years ago where nobody really knew how
do you think so it's really hard to
predict though I mean I've had people
you've never heard of I've never heard
of come in and knock it out of the park
I've had I've had some celebs come in
you're like yes is gonna be oh really
and it's hard and it's like pulling
teeth I've had a whole different ball
game when ya behind the mic you know
it's just a different kind of dance
really you like separating your cell
your voice from your cell phone what's
in a way that they are like doing the
opposite or have there are some amazing
voice actors that would probably suck
terribly on film and then film actors
that are just not very good behind Mike
because you rely on different abilities
when you're doing each one so on camera
you know if you're zoomed into your eyes
you see so much of what's going on in
somebody's face but that doesn't
transfer necessarily to their voice and
they're used to being able to register
from here yeah and so when they get
behind a mic it's really really flat and
we're used to a lot of times having to
amplify everything we're doing in order
to get what we need across I'm one of
the things I've noticed that somebody
who like you know loves your work and
had loved your work for years before I
ever broke into like the sort of the
press side of things is that I'd like
from talking to you guys and talking to
like people like Troy is that like
you're all so [ __ ] humble like in a
way that was kind of like like
unexpected is there like it where is
that coming from this seems to be like a
humility in a sort of that I get down to
earth miss that I was not I mean I that
is not associated with screen acting
well
I don't know I feel like it's just a
friendly crowd I I think it is a
friendly crowd yet and I think it's kind
of another yeah small community ish yeah
so I think everybody just knows each
other and then I mean everybody would
call each other out on their bullet like
what did you have yet not suck in a
little room with everybody so if
somebody's penis yeah yeah you know and
it's hard work as well it seems like I'm
not honest you can be yeah really hard
that's the weed out a lot also be
extremely fun like sometimes don't go in
and you have just a breeze of a session
and it's amazing and then other times
you go in and you scream for four hours
and it makes you sweat and you feel like
you're gonna cry and I've started crying
in sessions just from goodness Jen yes
good material yeah yeah crying is real
hot in games right a freebie it's all I
would have loved that if I could end
here is just like start crying yeah
great content why can't I get I guess
awesome we're gonna we're gonna change
it up and get some more y'all folks in
but what games are you working on right
now what what can people see can we even
talk about that's always the problem of
you guys it's like oh I would love to
talk to you about that except the games
out now Batman from Telltale Games okay
I'm playing cat woman in that and that's
gonna be releasing soon have you played
it yet I have it we're gonna go check it
out after this ok and then Gears of War
for leasing an October yeah what am I
saw of you working i I've just been i've
been working on minecraft the story mode
we've just been doing so many episodes
of that which has been super fun yeah
super fun but that's that's all right
now awesomo be something uh I'm
directing on lego dimensions lots of
lego stuff world of warcraft constantly
there's other things I I can see from
where I'm sitting but I like I know my /
and the shaft in a roof still there are
so many things that were not allowed to
talk about Winans I got Zelda persona 5
i am princess zelda wait headphones with
turtle beach you're working on those I'm
turtle beach headphones there we go bot
exclusively so the headphones you heard
it here first I thank you all so much
for coming on right now
you're you're you're good friends on a
date haha minute thank you so much for
watching the game spot co-op sage here
at the electronic triple it's the finals
a day 59 of e3 and stick around we got
matching Mercer Mercer a and travis
willingham on i had to talk about critic
roar back in a minute